you've been signing loads of autographs
today collect ammonia crave what
the people been asking you wise clever
interesting insightful questions general
one is why do they kill you in
everything but I still haven't asked you
know I come up with an answer for but
it's lovely it's these days are they're
a really nice way to sit and just just
chat to people all day and and you make
very interesting people and also some
great costumes which excites me so much
that you can look around and see this
incredible detail and work that goes
into these these creations like over
there over there yeah he's an actor of
course you get to dress up all the time
don't you but if you could take on a
cosplay costume you come to one of these
events dressed as someone who would you
come up I think at an event in a large
concrete hall in Milton Keynes as winter
approaches probably something like a
furry or a plushie I think determine as
there was a giant panda bear walking
around yesterday and I quite fancied his
costume I thought ooh bucket today so I
be another good shoe back is great but I
always I have great deal of sympathy for
those guys you see receive people with
these amazing eye other stormtrooper
costumes and things like that and I have
never want a stormtrooper but I've worn
those kind of costumes and you know how
much fun they are how uncomfortable they
are and how hot even on a cold day they
become later on so you love those guys
and they take their helmets off and they
just kept in sweats and the stench of
body odor that flies
enough to knock you out yeah now of
talking about the costumes that you've
worn as an answer
I mean what's been the most challenging
one was challenging costume um I think
whenever whenever there's an armor a bit
of armor on and I probably feel a lot of
the rings there was this incredibly
beautiful individually constructed armor
and that was apart from being
comfortable was on but you couldn't sit
down in it which was slightly
frustrating later in the day but the
great challenge was that is in any of
the fighting scenes quite often here ik
or a snap or a crack and you knew the
amount of work that had gone into this
piece and you know each piece was
individually crafted and a number of
people had worked to make it so
beautiful and then I'd move the wrong
way and snap it and you just feel like
an absolute heel so um for me that was
that was the hardest thing of just
constantly destroying other people's
hard work going sorry it's alright he
get another bit stuck in the key
battalion how many different bits you
had to have replayed I'm sure there is a
list somewhere big black list with red
pen written on it and some darts thrown
it one of the great bits of things I
learnt when I just started which which
is you know if there's any actors
listening remember this always hang your
costumer this is I some started in
theater and without question you would
look after your costume and you would
hang it and and ice that's the one thing
I see some people doing occasion they
take your custom they throw it on the
ground it just infuriates me cuz it's
yours a lot of people put their work
into it
sorry that's a rant but you know little
tip a lot of work put into the whole of
the Lord of the Rings world wasn't I
mean who you was the most surprising
thing that you saw behind the scenes it
would really kind of make fans go wow
that's incredible oh yeah I don't know
that it's sort of specific surprising
but but working on it the joy of working
on a show like that is is there was an
entire industry it was I you know in um
in the ye olden days a cathedral built
in a town it would create this entire
infrastructure around it of craftspeople
and an amazing industry and particularly
with rings that same thing happened you
got a number of because the detail
couldn't be machined everything had to
be hands handmade and the detail in that
film is so specific and perfect and
every prop you used every item of
clothing was a work of art and to create
that they gather together these amazing
artisans and craftspeople so you'd
wander through the different workshops
and you would see you know some guy from
the bush who hadn't been out of you know
had been living for the last 20 years up
a tree but who did the most amazing
leather work and you just be sitting
there kind of making these beautiful
things and that ran all the way through
the ethos of the production I suppose so
we at the you know shooting and had the
great joy whenever something was handed
to you were given to you it was so
beautiful there was no pretending it was
it was kind of your in the world so that
was really healthy was an actor I kind
of get into that character it makes it
makes the whole process so much easier
when the less make believe they let's
pretend you have to do about the other
stuff the more you can just slide into
that world and play with the other
person so it's um yes so I mean enormous
deal of respect for for that the whole
industry I guess that goes into getting
to that point of shooting a scene so
it's always a pleasure and I suppose
before Lord of the Rings actually
happened it was one of those books that
a lot of people would have thought was
not going to be film of all exactly so I
mean what did you think when you got the
call yourself the tape heart I kind of
had no doubt it was the the Peter and
Fran and and well you know that Peter
could shoot us and and the team he had
assembled could do it and Philip her and
Fran of his hoods works on crafting
these scripts loved those books so much
that there really was no doubt it was
doable I don't think any of us realized
quite how important were you know what I
wouldn't maybe not the right word but
but how the impact it would have
and then while the size of that impact
but what was so wonderful about those
three films is there was nothing cynical
about their creation they were they were
a labor of love for so many people and I
hadn't been a fan of the books I didn't
really know them you know I am but
realized after the fact how much they
mean to so many people and continued to
me so the responsibility obviously was
felt by those guys I didn't quite
realize them sort of but I think because
it came from such a good place in such a
genuine honest attempt to just share
their version of that magic and I think
that's why it was what kind of point
because he said you weren't into those
kind of Tolkien books that world at the
time at what point when you were
actually making the films did you think
wow this is something amazingly special
I was under no doubt that what was being
made was something wonderful especially
wonderful special that to say that
amount of passion that went into it it
was really only was really only after
shooting and I think I was invited to an
event and just talking to people
realizing what the books had meant to
them the importance of for a lot of
people those books were sort of that
pivotal you know adolescents time were
you trying to work out who you are and
everyone feels small everyone's like a
tiny hot bat facing this impossible task
of growing up
and uh some try and avoid it their whole
lives but
those those stories had been so
important those characters have been so
important and just speaking with people
and realizing how how valuable seeing
that story told in the right way and
been to them too so it was some see yeah
an honor to be to be a little part of
that which is love it and what was it
like being transformed into an L being
transformed into an L was sitting in the
makeup chair is always fun we're going
to you makeup artist this becomes your
closest friend on set and you have the
best times do you see they see you are
you their best and worst I die I must
admit I kind of see pictures of myself
as an often cringe and die inside but um
but the process is always enjoyable the
end result through no lack of talent
from the people assembling it it's just
entirely through me makes me cringe a
little bit but I guess thing I mean it's
not always a super early start when you
could have all that stuff done isn't it
yeah we was luckier I think the elves
you know have ears and wigs and things
but if you're an ORAC eye or a door for
a it's a lot harder so so the elves
shouldn't really complain if you're
having prosthetics stuck all over
yourself then that's not pleasant some
of those guys would start at night and
then work through to be ready in the
morning so who did you get to know best
when you were filming on set um I kind
of hang out with little hobbits
I suppose mainly I'm Billy Boyd and Dom
who
just are the noisiest good kids that's
fun
I would I would pop in and out so had
the had the great joy really of not
being exhausted from the two-year period
and where I just poppin fresh I was
doing another film Apple TV series up in
Auckland
so I'd pop down play for a couple of
weeks having a great time with them and
then pop off and and I think that sort
of injection kept them all a bit saying
to not just me but that while they went
on this enormous journey
they'd have new people pop in for a week
or so and to bring some fresh life from
the outside world so it was it was
always fun to to plunge back into their
world for we were we one of the ones who
got a tattoo as well tomorrow okay no I
have not a single tattoo on my body
everywoman but the thing with a tattoo
is I want a sleeve it's just they're so
cool and what was it like working with
Peter Jackson's all you already said
like it was incredible vision he had to
make this yeah I'd some work to them
though and on rings we've done a an
animatic which is like oh we recorded a
then it was two scripts that we got back
I did three scripts we recorded almost a
head it has a radio play which was then
animated together just to look at how it
would structure so we'd spend I think
about two weeks all working together
with those guys and I dumped bits and
pieces with them in the past so I sort
of
once you kind of know how how he sort of
works it's it's it's wonderfully simple
it's not you know he's not wonderfully
simple but the process is simple you
sort of know it doesn't feel
insurmountable you sort of get there and
he knows exactly what he wants he's seen
it already in his head so he can kind of
conveys then years ago yeah it feels
like making a little film just with the
resources around it and at no time did
it feel
it just felt easy in a way which is you
know physically not easy but but I don't
think anyone ever doubted the films
would be solid and good and quite
wonderful what's your best memory from
the time when you were filming um
usually the end of the day when you take
off armor and go oh god that's good and
and then the wig comes off and then you
do that on the scalp because your scalps
been oppressing us it's if you can
imagine the you go the hairdresser and
you get the scoutmasters how amazing
that is particularly if you're a little
hung over that little massage after a
wig on all day is about ten times it's
the sounds that would come out of the
makeup tell me love and then the great
joy with the ears was everything because
you could only use ears once and pull
them up and shoving things through them
so it was it became like what can we
pierce with today and then tearing those
suckers off so
I probably should have said something
more artistic but was the pure taking
off of the agony was so good the thing
those when people talk about getting the
prosthetics and all the wigs they say as
soon as you know if you've got a spinach
you'll know you can't do any by that all
time and you know where you discover
that certain things like paper clips can
be yea slid under something and
scratched or a cotton bud just or you
know wigs you you learn very quickly you
can't sort of do that you have to kind
of go it was something soft those are so
you learn these very odds strange
scratching techniques just tips yeah
scratching tips and I guess there's
people kind of watching over you're
going pray can you stop doing that yeah
it's where your hand away from okay
sorry and I just know okay why take the
hand away from the hair and away from
the wig it's a the wig cost more than
you do step back from the week you
mentioned about dying lots of things
there earlier I mean if it Goods have a
good death scene though death scene
steps into the best
because because yes it's just great fun
it's what we do when we the great secret
is you know for all the the books that
are written about acting and all the
philosophy behind you which it which is
all valid but there is still a big chunk
of it that is the same thing as when
you're a kid and you're playing
dress-ups and you know adventures and
when you're that kid you always want to
die you always want the big death things
yeah and it's um and a little bit of
that carries over I think into into
grown-up world where it's fine you've
got the blood Anders and I saw how
gruesomely am I gonna die oh that's
gruesome that's gonna be great so
looking about gruesome things how much
fun did you have making Sportacus I'd so
much gruesome fun on Spartacus it was I
think the most fun the most challenging
front overhead on a no television show
it was just glorious and on a show like
that we knew the sort of the character
arcs we knew the story arcs to the show
but each couple of weeks is a new
episode we've come out and we'd all just
sit down and be like oh how we gonna we
can't do that we can't they would never
let us do that only oh my god and the
joy you know there is pleasure in going
to work and crucifying someone there is
pleasure in slitting someone's throat
and chest in pretend lands not in real
and yeah you're getting to do the most
gruesome things and there were some days
on set where you know it's pretend and
you know it's prosthetic but there were
a couple of times and set where we all
made together all right different times
individually just where oh god this is
are we going too far here is this too
gruesome but it's wonderful I I'd give
it a monster on that show right it was a
bit of a monster he was some
it was a really nasty world it was a
world where where they were incredibly
violent incredibly cruel and I had just
had the great pleasure of being someone
who had enough power to be particularly
cruel and violent so yeah it's just a
laugh it's nothing funny about
crucifying people or padding throats
thanks but it's really fun when it's
pretend and blood and this is great
there's a whole department who-who have
a million different techniques of blood
so sometimes your customers right this
is ray of blood or it's out the nose or
outfit and all that stuff because you
know it's when you're on set it
absolutely be a fake but the joy of it
everyone sitting around going oh that's
great rip their face up we've enjoyed
everything you've done so far so you
look for seeing what's in your very kind
thank you so much for talking to me
you